captions
>> Please your cell phones and
mobile devices and this time.
Thank you.
>>
>> [ Applause ]
>> Good afternoon.
I'm pleased to welcome you to
Columbia.
I'm David Madigan, the
executive  vice presidents of
arts and sciences and Dean of
Faculty of Arts and Sciences.
I am pleased to welcome you.
At the outset I want to take a
moment to think the cosponsor.
The Committee on Global Thought
--  the CGT.
>> We are welcoming the Right
Honourable Sher Bahadur Deuba ,
Prime Minister of Nepal.
Nepal is a mountainous kingdom
containing eight out of 10
highest peaks.
Small nation situated between
two powerhouse neighbors --
India and China.
A country of breathtaking
beauty and the country that is
never been colonized.
Let's well-known is that for
the past 25 years the nation
has struggled with a series of
domestic political skirmishes
involving longtime monarchy
Maoist rebels and elected
politicians including the
Congress party.
>> The central objective for
Nepal has been to turn the page
on  this persistent political
instability.
So that the nation may focus on
the challenges that come with
being one of the poorest and
least developed nations in the
world.
There is evidence of this
occurring.
Two years ago after an extended
process marked by protests
Nepal  formally embraced a new
constitution.
To a remarkable degree the
Prime Minister's attorney has
mirrored his nations struggle
to achieve a stable democracy.
This is the fourth time he has
held this office.
The previous terms occurred
during the Civil War.
The journey has been a
difficult one.
Fourth for Mr. Deuba and Nepal
requiring  millions just
resilience and hope.
>> He was born and raised in
Nepal and he studied political
science and humanities in
Nepal.
Is a research fellow at the
London school of economics.
Throughout his career he has
worked to increase political
participation of ethnic
minorities and women and whirl
citizens another marginalized
Nepalese.
Tonight addressed will shed
light on Nepal's  ever to chart
a course to a brighter future.
Please join me in welcoming the
Prime Minister of Nepal , Prime
Minister Deuba.
>>
>>> [ Applause ]
Distinguished professors,
scholars and students
and friends of Nepal, ladies
and gentlemen,  I am honored to
be here to speak at this
gathering.
>> I have a sense of gratitude.
>> I feel that this has
cultivated perspective on
several issues and things of
importance.
>>
Mr. President, today I stand
here to highlight our struggle
for over half a century for
democracy.
It is a story of people in an
economically least developed
country.
>> Under the most difficult
circumstances and widespread
poverty.
>> The stories of this armed
conflict and about how the
Democratic process creates
conditions for ideas.
These stories are about
diversity and social cohesion
and citizenship.
>> The story of the people of
Nepal under the most difficult
circumstances demonstrates the
depth of our commitment to
democracy and these words.
>> I have devoted my entire
life and energy to the struggle
of democracy to the struggle of
the -- democracy in Nepal.
This has been many years of my
political beliefs.
I have been removed as prime
minister twice.
I have had difficult
circumstances.
>> Ladies and gentlemen, our
struggle with democracy began
in 1950.
The popular movement -- Haley a
new democracy.
>> The first prime minister --
>> [ Indiscernible - strong
accent ] --
>> In 1960 democracy suffered
a brutal blow.
The struggle for democracy
never subsides.
The people of Nepal never lost
hope.
We have continued under
difficult circumstances.
>> With three decades of
sacrifice we restore the system
of democracy in 1990.
We embraced this and opened the
market.
The economy grew pass.
-- Group fast.
>> The dividend was evident.
>> This was evident in economic
growth.
In 1993 -- 1994 under the
elected government.
Soon after this journey and a
difficult course followed that
lasted decades.
With these difficulties, this
led to uncertainty.
>>
This movement led to 2006 and
formally entered the armed
conflict and we participated in
an election.
>> We voted for and inclusive
assembly -- the assembly
declared Nepal  Federal
Democratic Republic of Nepal .
>> They promoted and inclusive
Constitution written by the
people in 2015.
>> This documented this process
for Federal Democratic Republic
of Nepal  and marked the
beginning of a new era of
peace.
>> The Constitution promoted
all ethnic groups and
communities.
And protected the rights of all
people.
>> The Constitution provides
all independent participation
and provides the Constitution
to promote and protect the
rights of women in all
communities.
One third of the women is
insured in the parliament and
40% of the local government.
>> This week we have concluded
the local elections.
We have had the participation
of all political parties in the
selection held for the first
time in 20 years -- they are
creating local diversion with
Democratic institutions
representing the interests of
people.
We hope to build leadership
from the grassroots.
>> We want our democracy to be
inclusive.
>> We are preparing for
elections for the provincial
parliament as mandated by the
Constitution.
>> It is my firm belief that
political freedoms in the
development of complementary.
We want to be highly inclusive
with our process.
>>
>>> We want to make people feel
that development is a part of
their life and liberty.
Nepal's  natural resources --
we look to enhance these with
the international community to
promote jobs, and to provide an
opportunity to make the best
use of progress and
development.
>> Distinguished friends, the
work is complex in a polarized
environment.
This has created a new security
for competition.
>> The rise of [ Indiscernible
]  and the rise of politics is
eroding principles.
>> We must find a common ground
and practice tolerance and
harmony to protect every
culture for real progress.
>> Nepal's is a culture with a
remarkable resilience of the
people.
The widest thought for humanity
comes from the mines in Nepal.
-- The mines in Nepal  of
beautiful coexistence.
>> This provides a path to
tolerance.
>> This is critical to building
trust and peace and progress
and prosperity.
We want to have connectivity to
create this.
>> Nepal is fiercely proud of
its historic individuals and
independent foreign policy.
Nepal's  has spirit without
fear.
>> Our long-standing policy has
been to have a friendship with
all and to work for peace and
prosperity.
>> Nepal remains alert to the
sensitivity.
>> We feel the UN has a great
role and responsibility in
this.
We must be more effective in
responding rapidly to global
challenges.
>> Friends, we would like to
touch upon the reasons.
The U.S. is one of the first
countries to establish
relations with Nepal  in the
1940s.
We have remained cooperative
due to mutual interests and
understanding.
>> The U.S. has supported
democracy in Nepal  and they
have continued good will for
economic development of Nepal.
>> We are encouraged by the
inclusion of Nepal and the
inclusion  of Nepal . We have
received a grant -- the largest
we have received.
This will help to harness our
resources.
It will contribute to the
mitigation of grievances.
>> We will continue to be a
preferred -- the U.S. will be
continue to be a preferred
destination for our students.
>> Such as a university like
yours --
>> Similarly, students visiting
Nepal for  tourism and
development -- this has
contributed to the development.
This has strongly helped our
people.
>> Let me express my desire to
promote greater collaboration
and cooperation between
Columbia University and the
universities in Nepal  in the
area of our common interests.
>> The academic sharing of
ideas and insights and
understandings.
There are several leaders in
the audience and I would love
to hear from their experiences.
>> I would now like to thank
once again the president of
Columbia University and the
members and friends of Nepal
and the students and the entire
family for receiving us so
warmly and for listening to me
with such acute interest.
Thank you very much.
>> [ Applause ]
>>
Thank you, Prime Minister Deuba
it's an honor to have you here.
Compact -- this is your second
time here.
It's time for our question and
answer session.
If you would like to ask a
question, stand behind one of
the microphones and I will take
questions.
You can do that now as I speak.
I encourage you to stand up and
do this.
>> I will take questions on
both sides.
Is the student we selected from
the undergraduate community on
global thought here to ask a
question?
>> The first question will be
from a member of the
undergraduate committee on
global thought.
Please state your name and your
affiliation.
>> Then you can ask a question.
>> Hello -- I am a freshman at
Columbia College.
Thank you.
I was wondering what advice you
would give to world leaders to
make the world safer and more
unified?
>> What advice would you give
to world leaders to make the
world more safe and unified.
>> Thank you.
I think the leaders should have
a talk and find solutions.
>> Thank you.
>> This side.
>> Hello.
I'm from Nepal  and a
journalism student here at the
graduate school of journalism.
I would like to congratulate
your government for holding the
elections.
My question is, how does your
government look forward to
resolving the crisis that has
been going on for two years
since the new Constitution was
created?
And since you talked about good
governance, how do you defend
the largest cabinet that you
have right now in Nepal  in
politics?
>> First I would like to answer
about the cabinet.
According to the Constitution
10% of this number -- 600 of
the assembly.
The cabinet is according to the
Constitution.
It is still a small number.
>> Regarding your question
about this, we tried to
accommodate some of the demand
in the Constitution.
Unfortunately, we couldn't.
We couldn't pass the amendment
because we needed two thirds of
the majority.
Therefore, we couldn't pass
this.
We tried to accommodate some of
the demands.
I think they realized -- I
think they understand this.
>> We continue to be flexible.
We can be reformed according to
the wishes of the people.
Thank you very much.
>>
>>> Hello -- thank you for
being here.
I'm Kevin, a graduate student
in the history department.
I have a question as the leader
of a country who went through a
natural disaster a few years
ago.
What is a some advice you have
for international organizations
the world community regarding
responses to natural disasters
happening now?
>> Thank you for this question.
We have witnessed devastating
-- they have witnessed
devastating earthquakes
recently.
Unfortunately we recently had a
flood in Nepal.
Regarding the earthquake, it's
not easy to find a solution.
Nobody knows when they will
happen.
Nepal is aware  of these
earthquakes.
With these disasters we hope to
deal with this.
In regard to the flood -- there
should be a plan for these
things that happen.
In the southern part of Nepal
there was a flood.
There are many opinions about
these floods.
Why these disasters occur.
We need to have some policies
for this.
Maybe it can be mitigated by
building storage so that with
the monsoons the water can be
controlled and Nepal  cannot
cope with climate change,
unfortunately come nowadays.
Nepal  cannot cope with this.
As a homemade the University --
as a whole AB the University
can create international
opinion so that the greenhouse
emissions can be control.
>> Thank you.
>> My name is [ Indiscernible ]
--  I in my first year at
Columbia in the engineering
school.
My question is -- I have seen
many in Nepal discriminate
against those who they do not
consider to be Nepalese.
How do you  promote to change
this attitude?
From all backgrounds.
>> I don't think there is any
discrimination.
>> Specifically toward this
group in Nepal --  they don't
completely accept that people
of all backgrounds can live in
Nepal.
>> There are some problems and
we need to solve these
problems.
There is a problem in some
areas.
With time we hope to no longer
have these disparities.
>>
>>> Thank you.
>> Hello -- thank you for your
speech.
I'm a senior at Columbia
College studying literature.
My question is about the rights
of the LGBT community and Nepal
--  they have been the world
leader particularly in
Southeast Asia.
In 2007 the Nepalese  court
decriminalized homosexuality
and in 2015 they had specific
revisions for
antidiscrimination policies
against members of this
community for which I don't
think the country has given
enough credit.
In the to years since, what
tangible measures have you
taken to make sure that the
community is protected and what
benefits are extended in terms
of healthcare and other things
necessary?
>> According to the
Constitution everyone has equal
rights.
Again, we need to have some
sort of education about this.
Unfortunately Nepalese have
some difficulty.
There needs to be adaptability.
Nepalese must work on this
issue.
>> Thank you.
>> Hello -- I'm a Masters
student in mechanical
engineering.
Thank you for being here.
I was wondering, considering
that some smaller developing
nations have seen significant
levels of foreign direct
investment, as a result of
their intellectual property
policy, how does Nepal plan to
move  forward with their
intellectual property policies
concerning patents and
trademarks for developing
technologies?
>> We guarantee property
rights.
We have a strong law on this.
We could have more on this
issue.
I don't think there's a problem
on this.
We guarantee this for people
that want to have intellectual
property rights.
>> Thank you.
>> Next?
Hello -- I a junior at Columbia
College.
Thank you for being here.
My question is, what are your
thoughts and feelings regarding
the young Nepalese men that
travel to the UK every year  to
serve in the Army?
>> As you know,
this problem is everywhere.
Between the United Kingdom and
Nepal,  we allow [
Indiscernible ].
>> Thank you.
>> Number state -- I am a first
year ethical student here at
Columbia.
My question is, the health care
system in Nepal.
I'm curious to know whether the
government is moving more
toward a socialized model of
healthcare.
And how it plans to ensure or
cover many citizens of Nepal.
Currently, coverage is minimal
and the cost are high.
>> That is correct.
The responsibility -- even in
the hospitals we don't
have enough doctors.
We have opened many medical
colleges for them to study --
they preferred to go to the UK
and U.S. Nowadays they are
realizing this.
Now we have hospitals with a
limited number of doctors.
We have 4 medical colleges.
I think there should be
healthcare for every household.
>> Thank you.
>> Thank you very much for
speaking today.
I am a senior studying English
literature and ecology
evolution.
>> As someone who studies
biology and especially with
your beautiful landscape what
you see for your conservation
efforts at such a critical time
for the next few decades?
>> Also, who is your favorite
Nepalese artist ? Thank you.
>>
>>> I hope that you agree with
me -- I like the artists.
>> Repeat the first question.
>> In regard to sustainable
development and conservation
efforts in Nepal.
>> Conservation efforts -- in
the past nobody cared about the
environment.
We have some ideas about this.
Still, we have to do more.
There is illegal poaching.
We need to plan to protect the
land and the animals.
>> Thank you.
>> Hello -- I a graduate
student in the school of arts
and sciences from Nepal.
My question is about
citizenship and the current
Constitution.
So many commenters have pointed
out that the Constitution as of
now is sexist and against and
discriminates against women.
For example, under article 11.7
a child born to a Nepali woman
married to a foreigner can only
get citizenship -- it
naturalized citizenship -- they
can't get a citizenship by
dissent.
>> When the law of the land --
the Constitution --
discriminates against women in
this and other ways, how can
you claim to be inclusive?
>> In Nepal -- they
immediately get citizenship.
In India they have to wait
seven years.
In Nepal Indian girls can marry
Nepalese and  immediately get
citizenship.
>> I'm talking about the
children of Nepali women who
marry foreigners.
Why are they only entitled to
naturalize citizenship whereas
foreigners who marry Nepali men
and have children -- those
children get citizenship by
dissent.
There is a double standard in
the Constitution.
As far as I know, neither you
nor your cabinet has come out
for or against these issues.
>> I agree with you there is
some disparity.
We will work on this.
>> Have you considered coming
out for against these articles?
>> I am in favorite.
>> Thank you.
>> Next --
>> I'm a freshman in the school
As you probably know Nepal  is
at an interesting crossroads.
It is in an interesting
location between two large
superpowers.
It has been a part of the
movement and it has found favor
in the East and West.
Has they become so economically
developed as it enters the next
generation do you feel that
there's more of an incline to
align with a Western economic
focus or and Eastern economic
focus?
Is more of the global market
for the neighboring market?
Which are you more inclined
toward?
>> The market economy --
therefore we are for the market
economy.
Still, we need to invest in
Nepal.
We welcome any investment in
As I said, we have a policy of
a market economy.
We need investment.
Without this, we cannot develop
our country.
>> Thank you.
>> Hello -- I am a freshman at
Barnard of Indian origin.
I want to congratulate your
government on passing a new law
against the tradition of [
Indiscernible ] --  what
measures will you take to
change the attitude of the
people and what more will be
done to protect the rights of
women in Nepal?
>> May I interject to ask you
to explain this term?
>> I believe it's where women
who are menstruating are sent
outside of the house and they
must stay in a hot for the
remainder -- and when they are
done they can come back to the
house.
>> Legally this is not allowed.
There are some practices.
>> What measures will you take?
>> We will police this.
>> How can you change the
attitude of the people?
>> We will have to.
Unfortunately, we have to
educate them -- we have to
educate society.
This will take some time.
>> Thank you so much.
>>
>>> Good evening --
>> Come closer.
>> Good evening -- you for a
great speech.
I'm a senior majoring in
sociology.
I am interested in foreign
policy in Nepal.
It is known that China and
India have been courting Nepal
recently.
Nepal  has been taking a
neutral stance on a range of
issues.
For example, the recent
standoff between the Indians
and Chinese.
>> My question is -- I wonder
could Nepal  maintain its
neutrality and not choose a
side in the future?
Because China has been more
ambitious and India in recent
years.
In terms of financial
investment and aid to Nepal.
What India offered is dwarfed
by what China has offered.
My question is, what is your
philosophy of dealing with
these two giants?
>> Nepal 's policy is dictated
by political reality.
-- Geopolitical reality.
They want to have a good
relationship with both
countries.
It is in the best interest of
Nepal.
We need to have good relations
with India and China.
We want to maintain these
relations.
We have these issues and we are
having negotiations right now.
>> Thank you.
>> Hello.
Thank you for your speech.
I am from the teachers College.
I have an extension to this
question -- what is the stance
of Nepal in terms of foreign
policy not only with India and
China but the broader  nations
that it is surrounded by in
terms of how you would for see
the next few years in terms of
foreign policy.
>> We have a good relation with
India and China.
And regarding this -- we want
to do this.
>> Next -- we need an
interpreter.
>> One moment.
>> Hello -- I'm happy to see
you here -- this is the first
time I've seen you here.
I'm curious -- I wanted to know
two things.
In Nepal  and colleges went we
talk about deaf children
hitting educated, there has not
been a lot of education for
deaf students and colleges.
We do see advancements for
other students, but not for the
deaf student.
>> Second, I want to talk about
interpreters in Nepal.
There are not many interpreters
because the government is not
willing to pay for
interpreters.
So, there aren't any
interpreters available.
But, then, we have a problem
with deaf people being able to
communicate when they go to
medical appointments and they
want to speak to their doctors.
What happens as a consequence
is that many die and don't get
proper medical care.
Want to ask about these things
-- education and medical care
for the deaf.
>> One more thing -- I am a
front Nepal.
I came here and now I am
studying technology at city
College.
>> [ Applause ]
>> I'm delighted to see a
Nepalese  who has studied in
Nepal  and came here.
You may be aware that at the
schools we have television with
interpreters.
Unfortunately, still there are
some people studying in these
schools.
Also in hospitals we need
interpreters.
This is important.
I will look into this matter.
The people who need this should
be given interpreters.
>> I will look into this.
>> [ Applause ]
>> I am a Masters student in
political science and a PhD
student in psychology from
Stanford.
>> Make survivor of the
earthquake and I worked in
Nepal.
As a psychologist we tend to
believe that mental health is
important.
I'm wondering for our people --
will you prioritize economic
development over other needs
for happiness and belonging?
How do you balance and navigate
limited resources to take care
of mental health and physical
health?
>> Thank you.
This is an important question.
Nepalese  people are break.
-- Brave.
>> They are coping with what
has happened.
They are great people.
They are brave people.
They have had trauma.
They have faced these issues
bravely.
Now we need to have some sort
of education so that we educate
people to be aware of this.
Buildings and houses and
schools.
>> I think in the future we
don't know when an earthquake
will happen.
They have coped with this and
now we need to have a program
and at the same time people are
receptive to construct new
buildings and new houses.
They should be buildings that
are earthquake proof.
I think if this happens there
would be less casualties and
trauma.
Thank you.
>> My name is [ Indiscernible ]
--  I am a student at the
teachers college studying the
conflict and power.
>> My question is more from the
standpoint of learning rather
than asking about political
issues.
I want to understand how Nepal
is a country  manages the
relation with India and China
is neighbors -- two big power
centers -- how does Nepal
manage to have its own identity
?
>> Thank you for this important
question.
We have had good relationships.
As I said before, Nepal's
interest is to have good
relationships.
India is supporting the
development of Nepal --  and
Sinai is supporting these
programs.
We have a good relationship
with both countries.
>> Thank you so much.
>>
>>> I am doing research at
Columbia the -- the University
medical center.
>> I want to know what Nepal is
doing  to help the Muslims in
Myanmar.
>> Oh, we are facing this
problem.
We are facing opportunities
with this problem.
It is a small country -- I think
we can deal with this.
>> Thank you.
>> I'm a graduate student at
teachers College.
My question is, what measures
the government taking to
address and achieve -- to
address the achievement gap
between the public and private
school systems in Nepal?
>> We allow private schools
and public schools.
As you said, it's not easy to
balance.
I believe they are good schools
and it depends on the economics
and the ability to pay.
In Nepal nowadays  the parents
want to send their children to
good schools.
>> Has your government
allocated any resources for the
development of these schools?
>> This is a priority of our
government.
We spend more money on these
areas than others.
>> Thank you.
>> We only have time for one
more question.
You have the honor of asking
the last question.
>> I study sustainability at
Columbia.
There are a lot of
environmental issues with
tourism.
There is a lot of -- I wonder
if your government is trying to
have equal tourism measures in
place.
To protect the natural
integrity of the country.
>> -- The national -- the
natural resources and the
country -- specifically,
Everest tourism.
>> Nowadays people come to
Nepal  -- we welcome them.
>> There was a lot of trash
this year that was never
removed from Mount Everest.
>> Yes, I agree.
>> For the local community --
>> This is a problem with the
Taurus.
>> The local governments have
the money to clean the trash.
To remove the trash.
Unfortunately, we will have to
do this.
>> Thank you.
>> Thank you, Prime Minister
for taking the time to speak
with us today and thank you for
taking the time to address so
many questions from the
audience.
Is there anything else you
would like to say?
>> Thank you for your good
questions.
I would like to answer more
Forgive me.
>> There's nothing to forgive.
>> Thank you for allowing me to
answer your questions.
>> [ Applause ]
>> I want to add that I'm the
U.S. but I've had the privilege
of spending time Nepal over the
past 15 years.
Listening to you speak and
especially -- especially during
the questions I was struck by
the themes touched on by
yourself and our students and
other community members.
Specific to Nepal and it goes
beyond Nepal --  these are
questions -- how to achieve
legal and social equality for
all persons residing in a
country to how to balance
environmental sustainability
with economic development --
these are questions that face
Nepal and the United States
and I daresay the rest of the
world.
We appreciate you taking the
time to share the unique aspect
of that Nepal has on dealing
with these issues.
Thank you so much for your time
and for honoring us with your
presence.
>> [ Applause ]
>>